there's this discussion over whether or
not a Hillary Clinton presidency would
be similar to a third President Obama
term many voters say it basically would
be an extension of President Obama's
first two terms his only two terms uh
and others say now it would be a
different thing it might be different in
this way or that way in some way Trump
is running against President Obama he
certainly is slamming President Obama
often enough where it's giving me the
impression that he thinks the Obama
legacy is at least relevant to people
deciding between him and Hillary Clinton
so it's really not good news for Donald
Trump that president obama's approval
rating is near an all-time high and it
is very clear that president obama is
going to have an active presence in
trying to elect his successor look at
the DNC right Donald Trump uh commenting
on the obama speech which happened on
wednesday night other times past times
in two thousand for example Bill Clinton
spoke on Monday at the DNC in support of
Al Gore Monday not exactly a prime time
slot things are only just getting going
in 2008 george w bush i will remind you
was so unpopular that he didn't speak at
all for nominee John McCain right they
didn't want George W Bush anywhere near
that thing but President Obama put on
the Wednesday night slot and it makes
sense because president obama's approval
rating is now fifty four percent the
might not sound high but when you
consider the extreme inherent
polarization of the American electorate
fifty four percent is actually quite
good uh highest approval rating since
just after his reelection in 2012 and
president obama is going to actually be
an asset to Hillary Clinton during the
campaign drastically different situation
than what John McCain had in 2008 with
george w bush and and also quite
different from what Al Gore had in the
year 2000 from Bill Clinton this is not
good for uh for for Donald Trump at all
and there's sort of two ideas as to why
president obama's approval rating is as
high as it is one is well he's just done
so many good things and in spite of as
actual
progressives having a number of
critiques of President Obama it sort of
makes sense that his approval would be
pretty high that that's one possible
analysis there's another one though
which is the Republican Party has been
such a bizarre freak show and Donald
Trump is such a disaster that it's
making people say wait a second
President Obama's really not that bad
when we think about the rhetoric of
Donald Trump and I think there is really
something to that and I would go even
further than that Louis when Donald
Trump makes these apocalyptic
fear-mongering declarations about how
terrible everything is some people write
some people are influenced by it but
some people here that and they say you
know what things aren't actually that
bad right now and I think it actually is
making them realize that things under
President Obama haven't been so bad so I
believe this is bad for Trump but I also
believe it is the product of Trump in
many ways yeah the obama bashing uh what
was much more effective uh during the
last presidential election during the
midterms I don't see what good it's
doing here uh it just doesn't seem like
that effective strategy in it's
certainly not making up for all the
other dumb stuff he says and does
because the poll numbers showing us
what's what's really happening and
there's a last element i want to mention
we're almost eight years into president
obama's presidency meaning it's almost
over he still hasn't cancelled the
constitution he hasn't started burning
American flags he still has an installed
the Muslim theocracy he hasn't put
people in FEMA camps so really it's
error or taken everybody's guns etc so
maybe there is a growing group of voters
who say you know we've been hearing all
this garbage about what Obama was going
to do for eight years none of it has
happened maybe we should be skeptical of
the story that Donald Trump is telling
us about everything Obama's done and
everything Hillary will do because a lot
of it seems to not actually be happening
under President Obama just some thoughts
about why this is happening and why it's
not good for Donald Trump